congressman-elect Bernie Sanders
independent Vermont at-large seat in
your former role as the mayor of
Burlington Vermont you were in
Washington many times and working on a
variety of issues what is it like coming
here as a congressman elect well seems
them takes about two days to find out
where the bathrooms are it's the
bureaucracy is enormous and and what is
being thrown at us I think necessarily
is all kinds of information as to how
you put together your office how you
make sure that you obey all the rules
and you don't go to jail for taking
gifts that you shouldn't take on all
these other things so it's the first
impression is an enormous amount of
information that's being thrown at you
you're meeting all kinds of people
you're concentrating on trying to get on
to the committees of your choice in my
case there was a problem of whether or
not I would be within the Democratic
caucus or not and that took a lot of
work and effort you're being bombarded
in our case by at least several hundred
people who would like jobs by many
people the media who would like
interviews so it's it's been say the
very least an exhilarating and
interesting week have you been bombarded
more than most or less than most because
of your independent status in terms of
job applications I don't know I I
suspect that in all of the Cubbies that
I saw that the large numbers of
applications I think in terms of the
media we've probably gotten more enjoy
if you could explain to the audience a
little bit of the behind-the-scenes
maneuvering on the question of whether
or not you would join the Democratic
caucus okay I was elected as an
independent I served four terms as mayor
of the city of Burlington Vermont which
is a largest city in our state as an
independent and in fact Burlington
Vermont today is the only three party
city in the United States of America
where independents and progressives have
done very well against Democrats and
Republicans I ran as an independent in
this election received 56% of the vote
the Republican candidate received about
40% in the Democratic candidate received
3% having won is an independent and
intending very firmly to remain as an
independent the first concern that I had
is how do I make sure that I get good
committee assignments which represent
the needs of my state and what I
pledge the people of Vermont during the
campaign is that I would make request
entry into the Democratic caucus because
I wanted to make sure that we you know I
was not pushed aside and put on
irrelevant committees I am NOT a
Democrat but clearly of the two caucuses
my political philosophy is much closer
to the progressive wing of the
Democratic Party then clearly to the
Republican Party and that was what I
campaigned on in fact during this last
week year the Democratic caucus and
party has been very generous to me and
allowing me to attend a number of the
panel discussions in some of the
functions and so forth but for a variety
of reasons they have made a decision
that I will not be accepted into the
Democratic caucus on the other hand what
has evolved which is absolutely
satisfactory to me is their willingness
to say okay Bernie we will treat you the
same as we will any Democrat in terms of
committee assignments so I will put
forth my requests they will assign me
essentially to the committee of my
choice and I can't complain so I'm happy
about that
I will accrue seniority so I think the
agreement is a satisfactory one are
there any other aspects of being the
lone independent in Congress that that
you see as a downside I think the in
many ways the advantages outweigh the
disadvantages I think not being a member
of the Democratic caucus and getting the
committee assignments the advantage is
is I don't have a party hierarchy on top
of me and it gives me a little bit more
freedom to speak out on all of the
issues I think that the by and large in
this country today there is a growing
anger and frustration not only at
Congress who people feel is not
representing them but at the two-party
system I think you there was a poll
recently which indicated that something
like 53 percent of Americans don't know
the difference between the Democratic
Party and the Republican Party so being
on the outside have a little bit more
freedom to be critical of the leadership
of both parties we want to go to the
phones just as soon as we can for
congressman elect Bernie Sanders
independent of Vermont 202 six to eight
to five to five for viewers watching in
the eastern or central time zones to
zero to seven eight three to seven
twenty seven for those of you watching
in the mountain or Pacific time zones
not your first try to come to Washington
you're here now 1991 what do you hope to
accomplish well I'll tell you Susan
there are we could spend six hours
talking about all of the problems that
exist in this country I mean the crisis
in health care the fact that we have 15%
of our population without any health
insurance the collapse of our
educational system the fact that we are
spending 300 billion dollars on the
military despite the fact that the Cold
War is over the growing gap between the
rich and the poor I can go on and on the
fact that much of America is owned and
controlled by relatively few people but
I'll tell you honestly what I think the
most important problem is and where I
want to play at least some role and that
is that the average American to a
significant degree is giving up on
government to me the major crisis that
we face is that in this last election as
you know about 60% of the people were
given the choice of the Democratic and
Republican parties in Congress didn't
vote at all you know all of us are
dismayed that in South Africa for
example black people can't vote how many
of us know that in this country poor
people don't vote anymore the last
election presidential election in 1988
you had 50% of the people not choosing
to vote for the caucus or bush you have
a situation in this era of
anti-incumbency throw the bums out 96%
of these guys got re-elected so the
basic issue is how do you reinvigorate
democracy how to make the average
working person the elderly person the
poor person say you know what this is my
government those people in Washington
listen to me they are representing my
interest and they're not just standing
with the rich and the powerful against
me now how do you do that that has to do
with the media who owns it controls the
media it has to do with the two-party
system it has to do with campaign
financing and the fact that many of the
can't many of the candidates are heavily
indebted to wealthy people in
corporations who buy them who buy our
politicians and buy elections so how we
can begin the serious discussion the
national debate that we need which says
where do we want to go is a country who
has the power in this country how do we
democratize all of our institutions how
do we give working people power over
their own lives you know we freed the
slaves a long long time ago but in many
respects in many respects that I don't
mean to be rhetorical about it the
average
in person today has very little rights
corporations announced a worker comes to
work on a Friday and the corporation
says oh by the way we're moving to
Mexico you worked for our company 30
years here's a few bucks you have no
power to say over there you don't have
any power over your job so I think the
major challenge we face it's not only a
redistribution of wealth which is
important but a redistribution of power
making the average American feel this is
my country this is a democracy I can
shape the future the people don't feel
that now they sit down they watch the
tube for 40 or 50 hours a week they hold
their nose they vote for the lesser of
two evils now that that to me is that is
the major problem and once we can begin
to deal with it with that problem I
think other things will follow is
Washington set up to handle big-picture
questions no my impression is that it's
not I think we are we got you see the
problem not even in I'm talking about a
week I think the system is a
compartmentalized into hundreds of
different little little areas each of
which are important I don't mean to
suggest that they're not every committee
is dealing with billions of dollars here
and billions of dollars there but I
don't know that the Congress itself is
saying for example the first question
that I think the President of the United
States should ask the American people is
why don't you have any faith in us why
don't you vote why don't you participate
why do you have such contempt for
government and I think we should as a
Congress be dealing with that issue how
do you make the people once again have
faith in in their country and in their
government does the Congress do that I
don't think so Gloucester County
Virginia you're on the air ready Sanders
hello yes go ahead yes I hesitate to
address you but Mr Sanders we did meet
many years ago in Vermont and first of
all and foremost and most importantly I
want to congratulate you a thousand and
ten percent for winning winning under an
independent label this is one who has
voted forever for all the losers
registering as an independent etcetera
etcetera also understanding so well what
you stand for and wishing to give you
some
encouragement to whatever it takes
fight that socialist label it I was a
native-born Scandinavian I know what it
means to be a social democrat I know
humanity etc etc therein and I know what
you are trying to do and I just wish you
so very very well and I hope we can keep
in touch thank you why don't we let you
go at that point thanks for the car lot
of callers on the line okay well I think
the caller when you asked what I want to
accomplish I think clearly one of the
one of the things also that I want to do
is to make the concepts of democratic
socialism that is not authoritarianism
there's nothing to do with it part of
the serious discussion that perhaps
takes place in this country because I
think if you look at the two-party
system and the ideology they're about
separated by about a half an inch and we
need a much broader discussion of the
causes of our problems and the and and
the solutions to our problems so we can
inject some discussion as to what
democratic socialism might mean what
goes on in Scandinavia what has gone on
on social democracy and immoral
countries in Western Europe if I can
play some role in doing that I think all
of a couple of something Orlando
high but I certainly would like to well
I think you have the wrong guy if I'm
not mistaking congressman Lantos happens
to be no relationship to me at all if I
am not mistaken I believe the newly
represent the newly elected congressman
from New Hampshire is the son-in-law of
congressman lantau so you got the wrong
guy for better or worse okay thanks you
have a another question all right we
lost that caller your specific committee
assignments that you want to have are
what the three major committees
that I have requested to be on are
commerce and energy my understanding is
it's very difficult for any freshman to
get on that one I want that one if
possible because of my concern and
desire to see a national healthcare
system established in this country they
deal with health care the other
committee is education
in labor for the obvious reasons we have
back home the support of vast majorities
of the working people and of the unions
and I want to fight to improve the life
of working people education clearly is
an enormous issue for our teachers back
home for our parents and for the kids in
the third committee that I'm looking at
is banking finance and urban affairs as
a former mayor that's of interest to me
and given the tremendous about the
virtual collapse of the Savings and Loan
industry the problems in the commercial
banks and raising the issue of what in
fact should be the responsibility of the
banking industry to the communities in
which they serve is of great interest to
the Congress
I think it's a very good question I
think what happens and I don't really
think it's anybody's fault per se I mean
I think the Congress is fairly trying to
orient give give an orientation to the
new members tell you what to expect give
your briefings on the major issues I
think what your question asks though is
there a process by which newcomers get
sucked into the old way of doing
business in to the status quo way of
doing business
and I think not that it's intentional on
the part of the leadership but I think
that goes on as a matter of fact I ended
up I was teaching last year at the
Kennedy School at Harvard so I have some
familiarity with that process and I'll
be there next week part of the time and
part of the time will be back in Vermont
I think for me one of the very exciting
aspects of having been elected is that I
am going to be able to be making contact
and depending to a significant degree
upon a lot of very fine minds who are
not usually allowed to have much of an
impact on the Congress and I'm very
excited about that whether it's people
like Barry commoner or Jesse Jackson or
Pete
who have been active in the peace
movement or in the women's movement
people who very often have been on the
outside I am going to be looking to very
significantly to try to bring inside the
Congress and get ideas introduced that
are often not heard New York City hi
Bernie
congratulations for breaking that
stranglehold the Republicans or the
Democrats Rudy need really need to see
that and I'd really like to have your
opinion on well I mean your sort of
suggestion how more people can do this
how what does what still your background
in terms of organizing yourself your
your political base in Vermont is it
just something that was possible because
it wasn't Vermont or is it it is
possible outside of the state I got I
think it's it's possible in any and
every state in the country and I think
it's possible in every city in the
country I think the major approach that
one has got to to go the direction of
one has got to go is to begin to
understand that it is not impossible in
fact to be victorious you know very
often I talk to people they say oh the
mayor in my town is a terrible person
you know but we can't take them on we're
not powerful enough to take them on I
think what we did in Vermont and what we
did in Burlington ten years ago is just
start articulating the issues that face
the people of your community in other
words what's so amazing is is that
people seem to do everything else but
sit down and ask the very dumb-bunny
questions about what's going on in their
community so you asked the hard
questions articulate the real issues and
work very very hard we have been
successful in Burlington and in the
state of Vermont because we worked very
hard in this last campaign we put
together I would say a good thousand
volunteers who knocked on about just
tens of thousands of doors passed out
the literature but I think the main
point that I want to make is that it is
not as complicated as people think it is
the average American today is very angry
is disgusted with politics as usual I
think the job of those of us who are
progressives is simply to articulate
forcefully the issues within our
community in our country you know people
say you know you
crazy you can't talk about those issues
you can talk about those issues we have
got to redefine the nature of discussion
our position should be that it is the
Congress which is not talking about the
real issues and we have got to just do
that one advantage it might seem that
Vermont might have is buying media time
less expensive to do that in Vermont
than people in major market there is
truth to that and that is true and it is
also true that you know the City of
Burlington where I was mayor for eight
years has only 40,000 people it is a lot
harder and become mayor of New York or
Los Angeles but on the other hand there
are resources that people have in large
cities that we did not have in the state
of Vermont but the main point that I
want to make over and over again is I
think the average political activist
would be very very surprised to know
that when you begin the process of
knocking on doors people are gonna start
nodding your head their heads things
like you're right those people are way
out of touch you have my support it's
burned yes good evening good evening yes
to Mr Sanders uh congratulations I was
really happy to see that you were able
to get in the I've seen a lot of people
have seen what's happened since Reagan
came into office with the supply-side
economics and so my comment is this and
then you can make a comment is that I
really don't feel that Jesus Christ
would be a capitalist if anything Jesus
Christ was concerned with the cares
trying to help people so I'm gonna hang
up let you pick your comment well I
don't want to get into a religious
discussion but I think that any person
who has a deep sense of humanity must
understand that there is something
fundamentally wrong when you have some
people in our country who have billions
and billions of dollars in personal
wealth who live in the fanciest houses
who drive around in these stretch
limousines and their brothers and
sisters are sleeping out in the street
when the gap between the rich and the
poor is growing wider when we live in a
world today where today 35
and children in the third world have
starved to death and I think getting
back to the original discussion these
are some of the philosophical issues
that this country must debate is it
morally acceptable that some people have
so much they're not going to spend it in
a hundred lifetimes and other people
have nothing where some people have so
much power and other people are
powerless and I fear as the question
that you asked a few moments ago those
are not the issues that are debated by
Congress and I and I think this nation
not only in Congress we need to debate
these issues in our unions that are farm
organizations in the schools of America
where do we want to go are we happy with
the general direction of this country
and I think when we start asking those
questions you'll leave one would be
quite surprised that that many Americans
I think I'm not happy with the direction
that this country is going in we have
about 20 minutes left in our
conversation with Bernie Sanders this
evening our 90-minute program is devoted
to introducing you to some of the newly
elected members of Congress Tucson
Arizona you're next mister Sanders you
ran on the ticket in Vermont as an
independent would it not have been more
honest if you had run as a socialist and
as much as I believe you consider
yourself an avowed socialist am i
correct well you're correct that I ran
as an independent I'm not quite sure
what can avowed socialist if you mean am
i avowing it to you right now yeah I am
a democratic socialist I think my
response is is that I am also an
independent and politically what that
means is I'm not a Democrat and I'm not
a Republican in terms of why didn't I
run as a socialist because I'm not a
member of a socialist party I'm not a
member of any socialist organization I'm
an independent socialist but I think
your question then the similar question
might be asked of Democrats and
Republicans and say to them do they run
as Democrats slash capitalists were
Republican capitalists socialism to me
democratic socialism is a philosophical
outlook it is what I am and I don't
apologize for it but politically I
function as an independent and that's
what I am in Congress Durham North
Carolina yes Mr Sanders are you there
yes I'm right here I would like to ask
you in terms of the reach
Frenchman of socialism all over the
world notwithstanding your comments
about Scandinavia how you can purport to
go to Congress as a socialist and
basically use flag words like
redistribution of wealth and basically
say that those who work hard throughout
their lives another by the way I'm not
powerful or wealthy and take from those
who choose to work and work hard
throughout their working lives and those
who choose through no fault of their own
and in less fortunate circumstances and
basically you know go against the work
ethic in this country okay thanks let me
respond to that what is in clear decline
and and bank audits in decline I'm
delighted to see it in the client is
authoritarian communism which to me has
nothing to do at all with democratic
socialism authoritarian communism has
been a vicious political system which
over its length of time has resulted in
the murder of many many millions of
people as an economic system it has not
succeeded and I'm delighted to see its
demise that has nothing to do with
democratic socialism now we can argue
the achievements or lack of achievements
of France which has a socialist the
President as you know Sweden which has
had a Social Democratic government for
51 out of the last 57 years which has a
national health care system relatively
low unemployment which has free college
education for its people young people
which has a 90 percent voter turnout it
has its problems okay we could argue the
merits or demerits of of Austria in
other social democratic countries we
could argue how the new democratic party
is going to be doing in Ontario a right
party a social democratic party that won
a victory just a few months ago in
Canada but the first point that I want
to make is what I believe and has
nothing to do with communism and I'm
delighted to see the decline of
communism I think we can talk about if
we're going to broaden the discussion
we could also look at how capitalism if
you like laissez-faire capitalism has
done in this country when it has
resulted in right now is a collapse of a
healthcare system it's not only that
fifteen percent of our people have no
health insurance but you're looking at
tens of millions of people who are
frightened to go to the doctor or the
hospital because they can't afford
health care and what the bill might be
and we are one of two industrialized
nations in the world that do not have a
national health care system you could
talk about a system in which we are now
three trillion dollars in debt that's a
national debt throw another trillion
dollars on top of it for the savings and
loan fiasco so that every one of our
kids now is deeply in debt that's not a
particularly positive system a system in
which now we have three million people
sleeping out on the streets a system in
which millions of our kids are dropping
out of school we have a twenty five
percent dropout rate in high school so I
think there are many very serious
problems within our country that are
gonna have to be addressed and I think
the democratic socialist model might be
an effective way to start approaching
some of those problems to me I should
tell you that first thought what I would
be very satisfied with within my
definition of what democratic socialism
is about is just a couple of things
first thought national health care we
must determine as a nation whether all
of our people are entitled to health
care or we're going to continue the
health care system on the free-market
approach ok the profit mode you want
health care you have the money you can
get the best health care you want in
this country don't have the money you
get nothing I think that that's wrong so
I believe as a Democratic Socialist in
the concept of a national health care
system similar to what goes on in Canada
as it happens in terms of being a
Democratic Socialist I believe that all
of our people all of our young people
should be given equal opportunity for
the best quality education that they can
get it is an outrage that the best
colleges in this country now cost twenty
twenty three thousand dollars a year
many working-class low-income kids can
no longer afford to go to college that
many low-income communities in this
country are not providing their kids
with decent elementary or high school
education we must have quality education
for all of our kids in terms of other
basic necessities of life we're talking
about housing all right it's not just
the two or three million people are
sleeping out on the street but that many
of our people working people pay
thirty forty fifty percent of their
limited incomes for housing so for us
thought what I mean by being a
Democratic Socialist is that this nation
can't afford and must afford to provide
the basic necessities of life to all of
our people
that's health care that's education
that's housing first on Murray Kentucky
yes I'm a first-time caller thank you
have you and I enjoy the c-span program
very much I'd like to ask two questions
of representative Sanders one is his
opinion of whether it's fair or even
proper for a panel of senators to
determine the guilt or innocence of
other senators potential wrongdoing in
the so called Keating 5 hearing whether
it's proper it's something to me it
seems similar to a potential an accused
bank robber of being accused of being
judged by potential bank robbers you
might say okay I haven't heard anybody
bring up that point in these hearings
that whether it's fair or even proper
for senators to be determining the guilt
or innocence of other senators the other
question I had of representative Sanders
is how is it different what is the
difference between a socialist and a
communist as far as is there a
difference between the two all right
thank you sir appreciate the call yeah
try to differentiate difference in terms
of a lot of question it may have been
calling in at that exact time I mean
over there basically communism is an
authoritarian form of government which
does not respect people's civil rights
or right to participate in a democratic
political system democratic socialism
encourages that participation so you
have countries which have social
democratic countries have a fall highest
turnout in terms of voter participation
then does the United States of America
we have in fact one of the serious
problems time I want to try to address
is that we have now far and away the
lowest voter turnout of any
industrialized democracy in the world so
that entirely different systems in terms
of the so-called Deccan Seany
five that that process as I understand
that not being an expert on it I think
the Senate is now seeing whether or not
these members have violated the rules of
the Senate and I suspect that that is
problem next call comes from Rohnert
Park California hello yeah this is Bob
Bancroft and I live in Frank frank riggs
district and he failed to mention that
the Peace and Freedom Party got 15% in
that election so I think there's more
independents out there than our
mentioned but my question to you is
about the problem of health care in this
country because my fiance and I are both
employed full time we can't afford it
and I think that's something that you're
looking at addressing in this Congress
okay let me be when I campaigned for
office in Vermont there was no issue
that I talked about more than the crisis
in our health care system the fact that
it's out of control and that we need to
do what virtually the entire
industrialized world is doing we are the
odd people out our system is considered
throughout the world to be the weird and
strange system throughout most of the
industrialized world in fact with the
exception of South Africa every other
industrialized democracy has in one form
or another a national health care system
which says if you are a citizen of this
country you are entitled to all of the
health care you need with virtually no
out-of-pocket expense now the beauty of
national health care in this country is
that we can have national health care
without having to spend more money than
the current 650 billion dollars we're
spending on the non system that is
presently in existence and the reason
for that is that if you have a national
health care system similar to what goes
on in Canada you can do away with about
seventy billion dollars in terms of
billing expenses in terms of profit
taking in terms of bureaucracy you go
into a Canadian hospital you give them
their card you don't get billed anymore
there aren't 50 people in the basement
of that hospital figuring out whether
you have Blue Cross Blue Shield or
kinetic in general Dunning you when
you're late paying the bills you don't
have people working in doctors offices
worrying about how they're going to get
paid everybody gets paid it's the same
system there is one insurance company we
now have 1500 separate insurance
I think the very fundamental question
that we as Americans are gonna have to
ask in terms of health care do you want
a health care system whose function is
to provide the best quality health care
to the people to be deeply involved in
preventative medicine so that we don't
get sick what do you want a system which
is based on the profit motive where a
doctor looks at uses hey you got a great
disease we could make at least fifty
thousand dollars out of your disease
okay you have drug companies who are
ripping off people right and left during
the course of the campaign in Vermont
some pharmacists gave me some documents
which were very interesting I think it's
pretty widely known that prescription
drugs manufactured in the United States
are sold in Canada and in Europe for
significantly lower prices than they are
in this country why is that because the
national healthcare systems tells these
huge pharmaceutical companies you know
what you can't rip off our people you're
not gonna sell your product unless you
give us a fair price in this country the
drug companies get away with murder and
I should say literally murder how many
times I have talked as mayor of the city
of Burlington the elderly people who
said burning the choice I have to make
is between high-cost prescription drugs
or food that is an outrage okay
so I think the basic question is that we
provide health care to people in a non
profit way in a human way or do we see
it as another business in which certain
people the drug companies the insurance
companies the AMA and their friends the
medical equipment suppliers are able to
make tens of billions of dollars in
profit very simple question that needs
an enormous amount of debate our next
question comes from Paul Meyer in New
Jersey yes there's two questions I have
a slight prager one is with regards to
our participation in the United Nations
the our country as flawed as it is still
has a wonderful Bill of Rights and the
Constitution the UN Charter and the UN
activities are not under that they don't
have writ of habeas corpus or what have
you it seems like we're going towards a
new world order which i think is sort of
like monopoly statism so we're going to
have all the evils of the state's put
into a super state without the
protections of our
Constitution why are we being subjected
to the will of a of a super state that
doesn't have the same for the the
protections of our own Bill of Rights
thank you well I don't think that most
people including myself consider the
United Nations to be a super state in
which decisions of the United Nations
preempt the individual rights of a
particular country the United States or
any other country clearly the function
of the United Nations and it's an
enormous the important body and I hope
it in fact he gains more and more
strength we have got to finally as we
enter the 21st century begin to
understand that war is a human
abomination and that if nations have
conflicts they have got to be other ways
to solve those conflicts especially in
the era of nuclear weapons and chemical
weapons other than killing each other
that means there has to be serious
discussion that means there has to be
impartial bodies that help resolve
disputes so I think the function of the
United Nations is to bring the countries
of the world together where they can
talk rather than kill where disputes can
be solved peacefully and I very strongly
support that process and the United
Nations we haven't spent much time and I
have a caller so I can't ask you to
spend too much time on us and what you
believe the proper role of Congress in
the Persian Gulf question would be I
have very very deep concerns about the
direction that President Bush is taking
this country what Saddam Hussein did is
clearly absolutely wrong he has got to
get out of Kuwait he has got to free the
hostages and I have deep concerns about
him and other dictators around the world
having nuclear weapons or chemical
weapons I believe however that Saddam
Hussein can be defeated and we can
accomplish all of our goals without
having to go to war and seeing tens of
thousands of people killed and all kinds
of other problems resulting as because
of that war I believe that if we
continue the effort to put strong
economic pressure on him diplomatic
pressure if it takes a year if it takes
two years he will be defeated and we
will win and the world will win all of
the goals that we are fighting for
but what deeply concerns me is not only
the bloodshed and the huge cost I want
the president to go on television
tell the elderly people that if you go
to war and it costs fifty billion or a
hundred billion Social Security is gonna
be cut Medicare is gonna be cut your
property taxes are going up cuz they're
gonna cut back on every program that
emanates from the federal government I
want them to go on television and tell
people what that war will cost but most
importantly I believe now that the Cold
War is over it is a horrible precedent
to me the day after the cold war ends to
start another war against the
third-world nation that crisis and that
problem in my view can be solved
peacefully and I intend to play a
stronger role as I can in solving a
peacefully riverview Michigan all right
I just want to make one statement first
before I ask questions in my 65 years of
being reading a lot about it because I
find it very interesting I find it an
important how other people think they
such a little interest in it if they
read something in the paper and they
swallow it whole they have they don't
think about it when I say I voted for
Barry commoner you know say who is he
and I'm saying hey don't you read the
paper don't you know what's going on in
this world from Latin America over here
I believe I don't want to hear about it
they don't really care how do you I
think it's wonderful that you were
elected as an independent how did you
get people to be interested in this I
don't and I don't think it's that people
don't care I really don't believe that I
think that people are in despair how can
you not care whether your kid gets a
decent education how could you not care
if a company that you work for throws
you out on the streets and takes that
job to Mexico or Asia how could you not
care about if your kid is gonna get
called up to go to war and get killed or
if you can't afford health care people
care we have got to ask ourselves why it
is that in Europe and in Scandinavia 80
or 90 percent of the people vote they
are much more knowledgeable about the
issues of the day they talk about
politics in a
much more serious tone than we do in our
country time after time I talk to young
people students then go to Europe and
they come back they say oh my god
students in France know more about
American politics than my fellow
classmates know about I think it has to
do with two basic reasons number one the
fact that the two major parties do not
have any real philosophical or
ideological difference so there's not a
clash of ideas and I think second of all
the role of the media and I want to say
that I think see spend by the way does a
very good job in allowing the people
anything much broader understanding of
what's going on in this government than
was previously the case but you'll have
to look at the major networks do you
think that television in general
commercial television is at all
concerned about educating or informing
our people I don't think so the function
of commercial television is to make as
much money as they can for the owners of
the network's and for the people who are
advertised you don't see that serious
debate or serious programming on the
environmental crisis on the issues of
war peace occasionally you do I don't
want to be a hundred percent harsh but I
think that the media in this country the
corporately owned media does not do a
good job of telling the people that the
issues of the day are far more important
than the murder shows or the rape shows
or the sitcom shows and I think that has
got a chip me change in Vermont with a
three-way race what was a turnout in the
state it was pretty high I think it was
almost 60 percent I may be wrong but it
was pretty high Ventura California yes
congratulations congressman I had my
checks in the mail for your reelection
real quick question on banking next term
they want to deregulate the banks again
right I was wondering if they do
regulate that should we make it so that
the taxpayer doesn't have to pay any of
those insured deposit your views well I
think you know if you put you know five
thousand dollars in a bank you have the
right to be to know that it is being
insured by the unite the Faith and
Credit of the United States government
to me the basic issue in terms of
banking is this the money that is put in
the bank belongs to the people of this
country and I think that the people
should have a say as to how that money
is invested
should it be reinvested in our
communities in creating decent paying
jobs
should it be invested in affordable
housing or should it be used for
speculation and and and types of
development projects
which benefit the rich for example so to
me the key issue in terms of banking is
to make sure that the money is used
productively that there's more
democratic input into how our money is
invested than is presently the case
Burlington Vermont well I know that
community
yes Bernie baby I'm calling from
Burlington Vermont and I know you too
and I want to say you know I'm one of
those people that voted for you and one
of my questions was well two of them
really was have you decided
or have they told you what committee
that they actually are really focusing
on putting you on and again what the
second question was how are you feeling
now being in Washington being around the
big guys who think they know everything
down there and focusing on their own
attention if you could tell me some of
that and I'll listen for your answer on
the television and again hey I'm glad
you're there man let's do it
thanks a lot that's nice to hear from
the people back home the first question
is in terms of committee assignment they
do not make fact public and will not
tell any member new member until January
to the best of my knowledge in terms of
the the second question how does it feel
to be around all these big guys well
it's it's pretty interesting you see all
these guys on television all the time
now you're suddenly in the room fact it
was amazing experience my wife and I
went to the president invited us to the
White House with all of the new members
it was a really strange experience
you're chatting with somebody you look
over your shoulder there's the president
the United States so I think what is
important to me is to understand that a
lot of what takes place in Congress
despite what many of the leaders I think
does not have a hell of a lot to do with
reality that in fact the people back
home and I miss believe me I've been
here already a week and I miss Vermont
we'll be going back in in a few days is
not to get sucked in into this process
by which Washington is defining what's
important this I think they're wrong
most of the time and I my roots are in
my state and I will stay as close to the
people as I possibly can you know the
most important fable that I've ever
heard is the Emperor without his clothes
and it has to do with who's crazy and
who's not crazy who's dealing with
reality who's not dealing with reality
and I think in Congress
are they dealing with billions of
dollars here and tens of billions of
dollars there I think they're very often
missing the point
so I intend to stay in contact with the
people back home and in fact try to
develop some mechanisms by which on a
regular basis for example putting
together not just town meetings but just
we did this in Burlington when I was a
mayor just methodology by which I've got
to be subjected to what the people you
know want from me what their views off
my job is to represent the people of my
state and not to forget where I came
from we're out of time thank you for
being with us this evening congressman
elect Bernie Sanders independent
representing at large the state of
Vermont have a good evening